[Música]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy arminia Fernández por Andrés espinal
Hoy les presentamos un especial sobre
Ucrania a propósito del primer
aniversario de la invasión nuestras
corresponsales en terreno Catalina Gómez
Ángel e Irene sabio nos traen algunas
historias con los involucrados y
afectados por este conflicto que aún no
tiene desenlace comenzamos con las
viudas de miles de soldados ucranianos
que han muerto este último año mientras
libraban una batalla con Rusia muchas de
estas mujeres aún no logran formalizar
el proceso de defunción de sus esposos
Irene sabio y Héctor estepa nos cuentan
más
dos veces por semana olena visita el
cementerio de lucha
Aquí está enterrado su marido o lexey
fue de los primeros en el listarse
cuando Rusia lanzó su invasión tenía 46
años y muy poca experiencia militar
murió dos meses Después de llegar al
frente alcanzado por un mortero
aulena le avisaron por teléfono
Sencillamente me llamaron y me dijeron
que habían encontrado su cuerpo por lo
que necesitaban fotografías de él para
identificarlo eso fue todo
es presidenta de una de las asociaciones
que dan apoyo a viudas y familiares de
soldados muertos en la guerra le
preocupa la gran cantidad de
combatientes desaparecidos
más
o menos tenemos un gran problema con los
intercambios de cuerpos desde el 24 de
febrero de 2022 no hemos podido
recuperar casi Ninguno de los
territorios ocupados por Rusia
Esta es la casa que tetiana estaba
construyendo con su marido
basil murió gersón y dejó huérfana a
Verónica de cinco años
su esposa cuenta que aún no ha acabado
el proceso para formalizar el deceso
hemos terminado todo el papeleo y
rellenado todos los documentos y estamos
esperando aún no tenemos noticias
la demografía de Ucrania está cambiando
drásticamente con la guerra
cada jornada de combates decenas de
hombres se van para no volver y la vida
de sus familias cambia para siempre
gerson estuvo bajo invasión rusa durante
ocho meses fue la única capital de
provincia en caer bajo el control de
Moscú al comienzo de la invasión de la
gran escala Durante este tiempo decenas
de individuos se volcaron a proteger y
apoyar a los más vulnerables
especialmente ancianos y niños Catalina
Gómez y miquel conate han estado con dos
de los protagonistas que salvaron la
vida de personas en gersón
no importa los ataques continuos sobre
gersón tal como lo hace todos los días
Lila ha venido a ayudar a espetlana de
77 años que no puede moverse por su
cuenta después de que tuvo una caída
hace tres meses
se quedó sola cuando su hija y sus
nietos se fueron huyendo de la invasión
rusa en gersón que se extendió durante
ocho meses en aquel momento la mujer
llamó a la organización a la que
pertenece Lila y pidió que cuidaran de
su madre
[Música]
Lila es una de las tantas mujeres y
hombres que Durante este último año han
dedicado su vida a ayudar a los
habitantes de la ciudad especialmente
personas mayores y niños ocupada
Es difícil compramos todo por nuestra
cuenta nadie nos da una bombilla ni
cobijas ni pañales es como si gersón
guardara silencio
lidera la entrega de ayuda humanitaria
más de mil niños y sus familias que
permanecen en la ciudad
hay niños que tienen miedo de salir
miedo a los tiros hay niños que ya han
empezado a
tartamudearé
su trabajo como voluntario es solo una
de sus facetas también es el director de
uno de los hogares que cuidan de niños
que se han quedado sin padres en este
vídeo muestra el día que los oficiales
rusos llegaron al centro En búsqueda a
los niños que para entonces él había
logrado reubicar en casas de sus
familias logró proteger a 46 niños y
adolescentes y evitar que fueran
llevados a Rusia si volviera a suceder
me quedaría un 100% con los niños y
Haría todo lo posible para sacarlos
y miles de personas que han pasado a
convertirse en héroes en este último año
en Ucrania
el mismo día que comenzó la invasión
rusa miles de mujeres y hombres se
alistaron para defender el país unos
fueron enviados al ejército pero Quienes
no tenían mayor experiencia fueron
trasladados a las defensas territoriales
o incorporados a la institución militar
la mayoría de ellos no tenían
entrenamiento militar y han aprendido
durante estos 12 meses de guerra
nuestros enviados especiales Catalina
Gómez miquel conate y oreja aladdins
visitaron este centro de entrenamiento
donde les dan más herramientas para
aprender a enfrentar al enemigo
la guerra no da respiro las tácticas del
enemigo cambian y los hombres en el
frente no pueden parar su entrenamiento
cada gota de sudor durante la práctica
tiene un impacto positivo en el campo de
batalla
un hombre y una mujer bien entrenadas
pueden salvar muchas vidas después de
que el último pise lazo el grupo debe
continuar el movimiento
cuando conoces las tácticas del enemigo
puedes prevenir neutralizarlo y
conseguir la victoria
la mayoría de estos hombres y mujeres
tenían vidas civiles antes de esa gran
invasión hace un año entonces tomaron
las armas y muchos de ellos se unieron a
las defensas territoriales que pasaron
más tarde a ser parte del ejército y
donde entonces están luchando en el
frente de batalla
estos hombres tuvieron que aprender lo
que hoy saben durante la Guerra esto se
opone a los soldados profesionales que
son entrenados por años Este es el caso
de andrei que era entrenador de fútbol
hasta hace un año
Entonces no podíamos imaginar que nos
pasaría en una semana o un mes al
comienzo pensábamos que la guerra no
duraría tanto como ha sido pero desde el
comienzo todos estábamos preparados
tanto moralmente como psicológicamente
todo esto se han hecho cosas de un gran
sacrificio
si no era nosotros Entonces quién
tenemos unas familias unos parientes una
nación y Alguien tiene que protegerlos
antes de la invasión Yuri era cantante
sus compañeros lo llaman Pavarotti
acepta recordar su vida pasada pero
evita extenderse
[Música]
en pocos días estos hombres regresarán
al frente de la región del sur de
saporilla Ahora tiene más herramientas
para enfrentar al enemigo pero también
saben que no serán meses fáciles aquí se
espera una ofensiva rusa próximamente
en Ucrania la población civil ha huido
de muchas zonas cerca del frente o
retomadas después de meses de ocupación
rusa los focos que quedan viven en
condiciones difíciles Irene sabio y
Héctor estepa han recorrido algunos de
estos pueblos fantasmas en el don vast y
en la región de harquif para contar las
historias de quienes han decidido no
abandonar su hogar
autos carbonizados casas destrozadas por
los misiles pintadas de la letra Z del
ejército ruso la guerra en Ucrania está
dejando decenas de pueblos arrasados
casi completamente deshabitados por la
población civil como esta aldea en el
don vass
Antón trabajaba como guardia de
seguridad en un complejo turístico del
pueblo hasta que empezó la invasión
ahora es soldado y lucha la cercana
alugangsk regresa aquí para ver lo que
queda en pie y dar comida a algunos
ancianos que no quieren irse
hemos evacuado a casi todas las personas
que conozco y ahora esto se ha dejado
así no veo razones para que algo se
reconstruya Aquí no hay nada que
reconstruir creo que se quedará de esta
manera
aquí hay casi exclusivamente militares y
el escenario es de destrucción total las
casas que vemos están calcinadas
arrasadas hay Muy pocas personas en las
calles solo pasan vehículos que
probablemente se dirigen a las
principales frentes de batalla que están
a pocos kilómetros de aquí
muchos de los pueblos fantasmas están
cerca del frente o Fueron retomados por
Ucrania después de meses de ocupación
rusa en esta aldea vivían 1300
habitantes pero la mayoría la abandonó
tras los primeros ataques tetiana es una
de las pocas personas que no se han ido
un reloj y una radio que funciona mal
marcan el paso de sus días
A dónde podríamos ir tenemos aquí
nuestra tierra nuestros tractores lo que
necesitamos para nuestra granja También
tenemos tres vacas que son como parte de
la familia Cómo podríamos abandonarlas
al marido de Tatiana lo iría una mina y
el esposo de su amiga lo mató un misil
ella ahora sobrevive sin gas
electricidad y agua corriente y con el
miedo en el cuerpo
hasta aquí corresponsales siga con la
programación de France 24 y France
24.com